welcome to cs 105 everyone
i'm patrick young i've been a lecturer
in the computer science department for
over 20 years i specialize in teaching
non-technical students about computing
and computer science
cs105 provides a broad based
introduction to
computer science and computing
for non-technical students i think this
is a very important topic
as you know so much of your life is
now online or done with computers having
a
good understanding of what the strengths
and weaknesses of computers and the
internet are
is really important as staff for
students
we view you all as potential future
leaders
of you know the 21st century and
as you move forward as leaders or just
as citizens
having an understanding of how computing
works
and how the internet works and how the
underlying technology
works is going to be critical as you
make decisions for either your
organizations
or for our country or for our world
and so that's really what we're looking
for cs105
we're trying to provide you with a broad
background so you can
understand what's going on whether you
read news articles
or you know you're confronted with
business decisions or personal decisions
uh having to do computing
and that you'll have a good idea on
what's going on
along the way we're going to teach you
some practical skills
we're probably going to spend about 30
to 40 percent of the class
uh working on web pages and web
technology
and we're going to get to building some
quite complex web pages and by the end
of
our time working with web pages i'm
going to show you how to reproduce parts
of the new york times front page and the
washington post front page
using the technologies we're going to be
teaching you
in addition we're going to be showing
you uh
you know talking in quite some depth
about issues like
computer security we're going to spend a
full week talking about computer
security
how your computer can get attacked how
you can protect your computer
we're going to be spending time talking
about um computer graphics
how uh you know those 3d visuals in in
movies are made
and we're going to talk about how 3d
music works
um we're going to spend a bit of time
programming so you have a sense of what
programming looks like
um so we're going to be covering quite a
few topics
and as i said we will actually be
covering some of them in a fair bit of
depth
um at one point we're going to take
apart a computer and show you what the
different parts of the computer look
like
we're going to talk about how the
internet works and how the internet
doesn't work
uh some things that can go wrong with
the internet
so overall i think this is a really fun
really interesting class
i'm somewhat biased since i created the
class but uh
i think it's a great time and i'm
looking forward to working with all of
you